hello the Internet I'm gap under where
diploma guys and we have all we do have
four tuples in place and a big air
compressor
yes that's 110 psi compression voice is
sort of rated psi of sport for 10 maybe
so actually going to annoy you they're
gonna get the choice so we'll have to do
it in a American booty so I'm gonna have
to pump it up still it's like sort of
maximum maybe 15 psi item on that 20
risking it should the needle in one that
build up pressure on here and then I'm
going to crank up the volume for max and
just sort of run away after school run
away do that start and hit one you're
going to have 2.5 seconds to press the
button please manage it
I can handle pressure
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I'm going to go before a chance to get
back so no less that's what God really
yeah flip an egg lit little wrinkly it
goes to the other side means of the
rabbit flip men the Sun air balloon
comes out and then that place there in
the blue such a quick time as of this
what happens when absolutely refers they
call off this top corner absolutely
Niall ate itself ripped apart all the
stitches to give a play football with
just to the end of it yeah I remember my
front 98 balls
yeah you can sort disintegrate on the
outside but we cannot give up at home we
had it means I'm having like a bobble
every out I was and it we just like
going around everywhere so we just
pulled it out over the end of it brings
like for memory all right so that's the
real football done maybe through an
American football next to sensible okay
sure next maybe anyway where it laces
out
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our arms ripping it is the rainbow
rainbow can you do bungle well if you
sound like I'll forget it this one split
down the width of it it's team yeah the
Krakens want to play American football
once
first of all is that your first
interaction with an American football
funds yeah it almost turned itself
inside out Italy
blew itself around itself wrinkly like
that and then just hug it off sheriff
let's go isn't it magical hand is right
there gets loads a bit a lot of pressure
with a rupture wound of a pressure
builder so different you just that's the
only ways I could happen is shred you
later
it looks like don't take me physically
yeah yeah it's one really ever done yeah
well hope you enjoyed that mindless
piece of destruction feel free to follow
us on Twitter we also have a second
channel and we have merch Grossman
starting a new line of hat oh yeah
these make it happen we try pretty faces
are your the display furthermore you
looks a little salted or like your like
that out brochure right yeah Middle East
involves this market thanks for watching
that video and we'll see you next time
not the smartest one way at least while
anything ends like this comes with point
so